let's talk about your father do you know  why he kept you in the forest  did you tell you where he was going we  are all worried about him you're safe  now she's faking Richards get out of  there  [Music]  it's a me like I'm I see why I have to  find her before she finds us  she done said if anyone asks I grow this  man exist I'm not safe people were  trying to add me on here to trust me  [Music]  I can't trust anyone the world isn't  fair  I want to give you a normal life but I'm  not normal  Am I  [Music]  secret destroy take her out to the flame  where did you grow up why do you think  I'm weird I think you're wonderful  [Music]  it's time there's Hana do you know how  dangerous she is  I don't want to lose you then what's the  cuts why do they want to leave she  smells of fear like a fox that knows  it's dying  [Music]  you